[Music]
life is full of plot twists along the
way
i've come into possession of a villa in
the south of france
what you never thought to turn it down
do i look as if i turn down a villa in
the south of france
times change and we must change with
them oh i like the sound of that
downton abbey a new era the modern world
comes to downtown
the grand event begins only in theaters
there may be new faces coming in but
the public won't want to say goodbye to
all their old favorites
you can all look this way please
[Music]
this friday
you steer ahead you're the captain now
welcome to modern times
return to the theater camera
for the ending that will leave you
breathless granny you would tell me
wouldn't you what do you think
we've been there for the story of their
lives i'm not quite ready to say goodbye
to danton
women like us fall into two categories
dragons and fools
be there for the epic chapter that
cannot be missed you must make sure they
think of you as a dragon
downton abbey a new era ready pg the
motion picture event returns only in
theaters friday
[Music]